you know there's a gospel saying which
is of course impossible to comprehend or
believe knock and the door will open
asking you will receive seek and you
will find and people think well no way
the world's not constituted like that
it's like it goes back to the idea of
aim if you don't aim at it you're not
going to hit it what do you mean by ask
and what do you mean by want because it
isn't just some casual request you know
you're praying to God I wish you know I
wish I could find my wallet or something
like that as if he's a casual grantor of
Magical Wishes like fairy with a magic
wand you know it's not that it's asking
means something like this I am willing
to give up everything that I'm doing
wrong so that I can put things right if
I could know what right was you're on
your knees when you say that man and
maybe if you're on your knees you get
the answer and so that's worth thinking
about so you know if you knock and you
wanted to walk through and you asked and
you wanted to learn you know and you saw
it because you wanted to find maybe you
would receive and be answered and fine
but not without aim need motivation
watch the top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carl Michael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Jordan Peterson and my take
on his top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two protect your beliefs if
you don't have some notion of the Divine
then you'll believe any damn thing yeah
yeah right I think that's right and
that's what the kids are doing yeah well
I mean dostoevsky's comment on that was
if there's no God everything is
permitted you know and he did a lovely
job of analyzing that in well in crime
and punishment and the brothers
karamazov and I think it's true I think
you'll if you believe nothing you'll
fall for anything and I really do
believe that's the case and you know you
might say well
what what do you mean
you mentioned earlier that people like
to ask me if I believe in God and I
always think well
who are you to be asking that question
first of all you have some notion of
what you mean by believe that you think
is just accurate because you know what
believe means and so you have a a priori
theory about belief and now you're
asking me if my belief in God fits into
your a priority Theory it's how about we
start by questioning your a priority
theory of belief because I don't even
know what you mean by believe and
neither do you especially when we're
asking a question not
profound because it you know
do you believe in God there's two
Mysteries there well three you believe
God all three of those are subject to
um
question
I think people act out what they believe
and so when people ask me if I believe
in God I say generally that I act as if
God exists or I try to act as if God
exists and they're not very happy about
that because they want me to abide by
the rules of the implicit rules of their
question which is no
do you believe in the religious view as
a pseudo-scientific description of the
structure of reality it's like well
I don't even know how to answer that
question because it's so badly
formulated I can't get a handle on it
um
do you believe that there's something
divine well let's try to Define divine
here we can do that for for a moment
most of us have some sense that literary
stories differ in their depth that's
that I don't think that's an unwarranted
proposition some stories are shallow and
some stories are deep some stories are
ephemeral in some move you deeply
whatever that means it's a metaphor but
we understand what it means
imagine there are layers of literary
depth and one way of conceptualizing the
layers of literary depth is that the
deeper an idea is the more idea other
ideas depend on it
right and so you have fundamental ideas
that are fundamental because if you
shake that idea you shake all the ideas
that are dependent on them and then I
would say well the realm of the Divine
is the realm of the most fundamental
ideas and you don't get to believe in
that or not because the alternative is
to say well all ideas are equal in value
it's like okay well try acting then
and you can't because you can't act
unless you prioritize your beliefs and
if you prioritize them you arrange them
into a hierarchy and if you arrange them
into a hierarchy you accept the notion
of depth
and so that's a no-go
when we use language of the Divine we're
talking about the deepest ideas
and so I believe that
the notion that each individual
is characterized by a Consciousness that
transforms The Horizon of the future
into the present that's a Divine idea
it's so deep and our cultures
necessarily I think functional cultures
are necessarily predicated on that idea
so I don't just think it's a western
idea I don't think you can have a
functional culture that in some sense
doesn't instantiate that idea because
you interfere with the mechanism of
adaptation Itself by not allowing it
free expression
you know and you can be like my prime
minister and you can say well I really
admire the Chinese Communist party
because when it comes to environmental
issues they get things done and I think
I I couldn't begin to tell you how many
things are wrong with that statement
that would take like 15 years to tell
you why your uh an inexcusably
narcissistic idiot but we can start like
simply if you know what you're doing and
you have power if you know what you're
doing maybe you can be more efficient
in your exercise of in your control over
movement towards that goal let's just
assume for a minute that you do know
what you're doing well maybe if you have
power then you're efficient fair enough
man
what about when you don't know what
you're doing
how about then where do you turn because
what that means is your ideology failed
you and do you have a mechanism for
for operating when you don't know what
you're doing well no because we always
know what we're doing because we're
totalitarian and we have a complete
theory of everything and don't say
anything to the contrary or else we've
got it all wrapped up yeah except when
you don't
and so what do we do in free societies
when we don't know what we're doing well
we let people talk
and out of that Babble out of that noise
and American culture is particularly
remarkable in this regard you have this
immense diversity of opinions most of
which are completely useless and some of
which are absolutely Redemptive and one
of the things that's so remarkable as a
Canadian observing your culture in
particular is that you know you guys
Veer off in weird directions fairly
frequently and things look pretty
unstable and then there's some glimmer
of hope somewhere that bursts forward in
in a whole new mode of adaptation and
Away you go again and that just happens
over and over and over and that's a
consequence of real diversity of real
diversity and it's definitely a
consequence of like freedom of
Association and freedom of speech
because it enables all that rule number
three win over Temptations you're at a
crossroads right here entering a new
phase of your life you can
you're someone different than you were
four years ago
and hopefully someone better
likely someone better
and you have another opportunity now to
be the next iteration of yourself
that you can be
at a Crossroads you know
the metaphor works because you make a
decision you go One Direction or another
and there's an old blues idea that you
meet the devil at the crossroads I
always wondered why that was I thought
it through it's a really compelling
idea you know it's a it's an image that
has a good narrative fit and it sticks
in your memory once you hear it why do
you meet the devil at the crossroads at
midnight maybe that's when you let
examine your conscience
or it examines you
and then you might ask well why do you
meet the devil at the crossroads
and the answer is most fundamentally
because
when you come to a place in your life
where you have to make a choice
and I think this is actually true of
every choice we ever make but it's more
evident when the choice is more
weighty let's say
as the choices that lay themselves out
now in front of you are waiting you aim
up or down
and there is always an agent of
Temptation at every choice Point
enticing you
to aim down
and I thought a lot about what aiming
down means and so all
run through that for a bit the spirit of
Temptation manifests itself for example
in the story of Cain and Abel and so
Cain Falls prey to Temptation and God
bluntly informs him
when he complains about his fate that
the Temptation was freely Chosen and
that he could have done differently and
better and Cain becomes this is in the
aftermath of the improper
sacrifices that he makes
the sacrifices that he makes that are
not
everything they could be
they're not in the service of the
highest good
that are deceptive and arrogant
simultaneously because when we make
improper sacrifices we believe in the
deepest part of ourselves that we've
pulled one over God
and Isis suggests that that's a
Temptation you might want to avoid that
presumption
and then you might say well if you're
tempted to aim down
you're tempted to make improper
sacrifices you're tempted to arrogantly
presume that you are going to get away
from it with it that you're not going to
be called on it
what are the pathways down that might
manifest themselves in front of you and
I think the the two stories that follow
the story of Cain and Abel
detail that
so after Cain and Abel Comes The Flood
and that's no accident The Narrative
placement of those stories is definitely
no accidents it's unbelievably
sophisticated from a literary
perspective a philosophical perspective
theological perspective
existential perspective one form of
Temptation is
the nihilistic chaos that's symbolically
represented by the flood right it's the
proliferation of sins
and sin is a word
both its Greek and its Hebrew derivation
are related to archery so the Greek
derivation I hope I haven't got this
wrong because I know there are Greek
scholars in this audience so um the the
word is derived from the Greek word
hamartia which means to miss the mark
and it's an archery term it's lovely I
it's a lovely notion to know that
because to sin therefore means to miss
the target which implies that it has
something to do with aim or the lack
thereof I love that I think it's so apt
and the derivation of the word sin from
the Hebrew Source actually relies on the
same imagery and so to sin is to aim
wrong or to miss the mark and there's a
variety of ways you can miss the mark
right don't aim at all that's a good one
assume there is no such thing as aim
assume all aims are equal
well you sin you missed the mark what
can happen well one way is you can
descent into a kind of nihilistic
hopelessness and that's not you can
understand that you know you meet people
in life whose lives have been so hard
you know you hear their stories they've
suffered so much and they're bitter and
they're hurt and they're resentful and
you think oh my God it's no wonder
you're bitter and hurt and resentful I
mean look what you've gone through and
but you also notice that their
bitterness and their resentment and
their hopelessness and their chaos and
their anxiety it's not helping
right it's worsening the problem it's
not making it better and I'm not saying
that people can always resist that
but I I I've certainly seen that it's
not helpful but I've also met other
people you know who have had stories
equally catastrophic sometimes more
catastrophic sometimes so catastrophic
you can't even believe that they
survived who are not embittered or made
residential by those experiences and who
continue to aim up and so that makes a
mockery of the of the of a kind of
casual determinism right is that you end
up chaotic nihilistic hopeless anxious
Etc
merely as a consequence of the
unbearable tragedy of your life because
if that was the case then everyone who
had a series of unbearable tragedies
which by the way will be almost all of
us in one way or another at one time or
another would end up
in that catastrophic chaos that that
once
that if manifested broadly enough in a
society produces a flood of
that ends everything and that's well
that's the story of Noah in large part
and Noah you know he's wise in his
Generations was a lovely phrase because
it means for his time and place he was a
good man and that's that's a lens
through which history might well be
viewed you know we're very presumptuous
as moderns we look back and we think
well you know this person who did all
these remarkable things said these
things that we now regard as
inappropriate and therefore can be
dispensed with it's like well what makes
you think that you're above that
criticism 100 years from now that you
know the best you can do is to be as
good as you can in your time and place
and if you could manage that well good
for you if you can transcend that well
then maybe you're some sort of Saint and
you're probably not so aiming at just
the first is not such a bad upper aim
rule number four learn true
self-awareness first of all I do believe
that I don't think science is possible
outside of an encompassing
judeo-christian ethic
so for example I don't think you can be
a scientist without believing as an
axiom of faith that truth will set you
free or that will set us free so we
don't know the conditions under which
science is possible you know and we tend
to overestimate its
epistemological potency it's only been
around I mean you can stretch it back to
the Greeks if you're inclined but in a
formal sense it's only been around for
about five centuries and it's only
thrived for a very short period of time
and it's perfectly reasonable to assume
that there were particular preconditions
that made its rise and descendancy
possible it is a historical phenomenon
yes it happened at a specific moment in
time right and for and at least the
principles for particular reasons yeah
and I think one of the conditions well
there's a bunch of them one is for
example there there's an intense
insistence in the Christian tradition
that the mind of God in some sense is
knowable yes so we could say well the
structure of the cosmos and you have to
believe that that's the case before
you're going to embark on a scientific
Endeavor you have to believe that
there's some relationship between logos
logic let's say but logos is a much
broader concept than logic that's for
sure you have to believe that there's
some relationship between that and the
structure of the cosmos you have to
believe that the pursuit of truth is in
itself an ethical good because why would
you otherwise bother you have to believe
that there is such a thing as an ethical
good and those aren't scientific those
are not scientific questions which is
why I think the arguments of people like
Hitchens are weak it's like yeah
Hitchens Dawkins people like that they
have a metaphysic which they don't know
and they assume that metaphysic is
self-evidence like well sorry guys it's
actually not self-evident and they
assume that it can be derived from the
observations of empirical reality and
the answer to that is
no there's going to be axioms of your
perceptual system that aren't derivable
from the contents of your perceptual
system and you might think well that's
not very scientific and I would say well
take it up with Roger Penrose and see
what he thinks
because I just talked to him for like
three hours about partly about this
topic about say the role of
Consciousness and and the structure of
Consciousness and it's by no means
obvious that the materialist
reductionists have the correct
theory about the nature of Consciousness
and not surprisingly it's like we we
don't understand the relationship
between Consciousness and being at all
and so they're you know these are hard
hard questions well they're the hardest
the hard question for Consciousness
researchers is uh why is there
Consciousness rather than why aren't we
just unconscious mechanisms acting
deterministically they call that the
hard question I don't think that is the
hard question I think the hard question
is what's the relationship between
Consciousness and being itself and
because I don't I can't understand what
it means for something to be in the
absence of some awareness of that being
so when we say being there's an
awareness component implicit in the in
the idea of being itself Consciousness
is integrally tied up with being in some
mysterious Manner and so
and I also don't believe that the the
most sophisticated scientists are by
necessity reductionist materialists like
get as far as you can with that no
problem it's it's Occam's razor clear if
you can reduce and account
deterministically no problem but don't
be thinking that accounts for everything
because I don't think there's any
evidence that it does also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule 5. develop moral
Consciousness so imagine that you're in
Amsterdam during World War II and the
Nazis are everywhere and you have Jewish
Family in the attic and you're up there
with a baby and there's 25 Nazi officers
on the ground floor the baby starts to
cry
do you smother the baby you save all the
people upstairs and Claire who is a
mother of a very young child at that
time said her response was don't ask me
such stupid questions which I think is
actually the right response and it's
more embodied response right and you you
can trap your philosophical cognition
into weird corners but that doesn't mean
that your fundamental intuitions are
affordable this is right with this
nozick thing it's it's like well if you
could not have a body yeah you know
you're grounded out in the world that's
that's the rejection of Derek parfitt
right so Derek parfitt's entire moral
theories the trolley problems and you
can see how morality is constructed
based on trolley problems and people
like well that's not really how morality
is constructed it's not all based on
edge cases not really how it's
constructed at all it has to be embodied
for example and that's a crucial issue
you know and so the the notion that a
set of semantic philosophical
propositions even coherently organized
constitutes the ethical world and that
ethics is top down from
that's there's some truth in that
because there's feedback loops right we
think about ethics and we can we can
move around the edges of ethics and so
forth but it's within a game that's
already established and that game is
actually established through embodying
negotiation first so when you see Moses
leading his people through the desert
they're all fighting and scrapping away
right and then he sits as judge of them
for a very long period of time it's
months or years even so much that his
father-in-law says you have to stop
doing this because it's exhausting you
right it's after that he receives the
revelations from on high and so my sense
of that psychologically is it's a story
about the fact that morality is encoded
in our behavior in a deep level and so
deep we actually don't understand the
morality but then now and then we get an
imaginative insight into the moral
pattern and then we get a semantic
representation of the imaginative
insight and that's this Revelation it's
like here's a moral rule it's like
wolves suddenly becoming semantically
conscious of the Authority relationships
in their pack oh that's really good I
like that a lot that's quite good like
20 years
put a lot of effort into that yeah
there's a there's a there's a big kind
of Rich debate in Jewish philosophy over
whether Moses is right to listen to
Jethro so Jethro comes and says you need
to you need to devolve authority to
lower levels you need the the princess
you need the judges of the tens and then
the judges of The Hundred yeah yeah
which is a lovely way of thinking about
it too because it parse out I thought
that's what should have happened in Iraq
right kill the Tyranny well what do you
do you have to establish a hierarchical
local Authority exactly so centralized
control doesn't work but one of the big
questions is whether in doing that is
Moses setting the stage for all of the
chaos that follows because once you give
up the authority that he has the direct
Authority and you have now layers of of
authority below him how much Authority
can you devolve to layers below you
without giving up the the prime
Authority at the top right that is like
one of the Cardinal questions of life
isn't it you know if you have a family
you want to devolve a Authority and
facilitate autonomy and the question is
how much can you do that without without
generating disunity and I would say it
depends on the value of the goal that
unites you and and then that brings up
another question and this is a question
I would say for the moral relativists I
was talking to Rupert sheldrake in in
Cambridge he has lots of wild ideas but
I was conducting a seminar there on the
nature of the uniting ideal so it was
imitation of the Divine ideal so you
need a higher order aim to unite
subordinate drives right so the question
then is what becomes the highest order
yeah
epic great it's like the pyramid with a
gold cap on the top or the Washington
Monument with a pyramid on top of it
with this aluminum cap on something's at
the top and the thing that's at the top
is actually qualitatively distinctive
from all the things that are subordinate
to it so the question is well what's
that highest order uniting principle and
well one answer to that that the three
religions that are based on books have
proposed is it has something to do with
the authority of the word and
Christianity that's developed into the
notion of the Divine word and you see
that saturating Judaism as well and
that's at least in part because the
thing that has to be superordinate is
freedom of
it's not freedom of fight exactly it's
more like freedom of Consciousness
because logos isn't thought it's not
logic either it's much broader than that
it's more like Consciousness itself and
the reason I think that's true
technically is because
imagine that Consciousness and attention
are in some sense isomorphic right I
mean when we pay attention to something
we become conscious of it okay
Consciousness Consciousness is the
mechanism that generates proximal
Solutions and dissolves and regenerates
them and so all the proximal Solutions
have to be made subordinate to respect
for the process that generates old okay
yeah yeah I think it's a cardinal
presupposition of psychotherapy because
what you do in Psychotherapy is you
allow people maximal freedom of
expression right you don't impose your
views on them you the freudians use free
association say whatever comes into your
mind and it turns out that that process
of
untrammeled expression in good faith is
actually Curative it actually makes
people
better it leads them to what they're
afraid of that that's one of the
consequences of free speech right
because you sort of you tend to
circulate around what bothers you and
what disturbs you and so untrammeled
freedom of expression will lead you to
the source of your fears and then you
can confront those fears and then in
confronting them you can get more
courageous that's all part of that rule
number six be a better Storyteller the
other thing that that ideology does and
the radical leftists are all also very
good at this is that
it provides you with a local a
convenient Locale for the for the uh
existence of evil
and so if you reflexively identify the
patriarchy with evil
well first of all that's a powerful idea
it it independent of its broad Merit
it's a it's true
now it's not the only truth and it's not
the complete truth but it's true the
reason it's true is because every
hierarchical system hierarchical system
degenerates tends to degenerate in the
direction of power and all hierarchical
systems are less than they could be and
that's partly because of the possibility
that power and deceit will corrupt them
but also partly because we're willfully
blind and deceitful in our own personal
lives and so when you tell young people
that
the cause of the trouble they see around
them in the world and maybe even the
disquiet in their own heart is the
malevolent inadequacy of their society
that Rings true and they don't hear the
rest of the story you know and it's the
rest of the story that I've been trying
to tell they don't hear the story that
yeah don't forget about the evil and
Corruption that exists in your own heart
and don't forget about the fact that
nature
in this wondrous goddess as portrayed by
the anti-human environmentalists and I
by that I don't mean all
environmentalists by the way
that wonderful goddess nature is also
trying to
make you ill and kill you at all times
and so but the story that corruption
exists in hierarchical structure
and that that's a consequence of
malevolence the malevolent use of power
and deceit that's true
so it's very motivating especially if
you're young and you're looking for an
adventure now it's also too convenient
which is one of its tremendous dangers
Because unless you're taught to look
within and identify the malevolence
there as the primary moral obligation
then you now have an excuse and a moral
justification to take out all of your
negative emotion your hostility your
resentment everything about you that's
unexamined on the Demonic Enemy and of
course that's that that degenerates with
extraordinary rapidity as we as we've
seen over and over and over
so it's up to the it's up to the
centrists on both sides to to deal with
this I've been talking to a lot of The
Optimist rationalist Types on my podcast
Matt Ridley and Bjorn lomberg and well
and height and and Pinker more more
distantly but more recently uh Bloomberg
and and Ridley and and uh Mary and tupi
who who's written a lovely book on uh
human progress uh 10 things everyone
needs to know about human progress it's
something like that huh anyways
one of the things we discussed
consistently was the difficulty in
promoting the message that all three of
these men are very aware of which is
that from a material perspective in
terms of absolute privation
worldwide
humanity is way better off on virtually
every Dimension you could possibly
measure than ever and and most of that
Improvement has occurred in the last 40
years and it's been revolutionary in its
speed and no one knows this
and so it's very important to note to
try to think through why that is like
that's such a positive message now I
talked to Russell Brand about this and
I'm bringing him up for a reason he's
he's a lefty by temperament and by heart
and his first objection but he's very
thoughtful and quick his first objection
you know I pointed out all this data
showing that by every possible objective
measure everything is way better than it
was
certainly a hundred years ago but
certainly even 20 years ago even on the
environmental front in the main
and he said well what about disparity of
distribution so there's the problem of
absolute level of wealth let's say now
it's improving but there is still
tremendous disparity and of course that
that is fair enough you could even point
out that the role of the left is to
provide a conscientious voice for
for that's constantly attending to the
fact of continuing disparity regardless
of absolute level of wealth and fair
enough but
but having said all that
it's a great mystery that incremental
optimism is not sufficiently motivating
and you can't just wish human nature is
going to change it's not going to change
we got to tell a better story and I also
think that's why I'm a Target
I think is because I am actually trying
to tell a better story and I'm actually
having some Success With It rule number
seven have faith I think faith is a form
of courage
you know if you're hurt by life and you
will be
it's understandable that you might react
in a nihilistic and hopeless fashion and
become anxious and depressed and cynical
and bitter and all of that
uh that's a bad pathway
and I think part of what helps you
through that is Faith and and part of
that faith is that it's incumbent upon
you and actually in your best interest
and everyone else is to maintain faith
in the fundamental goodness of existence
including your own despite the evidence
to the contrary
right because you can draw conclusions
from suffering in two ways right one is
that you have a duty and perhaps the
capability to transcend the suffering
and still serve the good or you can
derive the conclusion that life is so
unbearable that it would be best
terminated which is the conclusion that
girth is Mephistopheles derives for
example in Faust he says well the world
is Rife with suffering and it's so
unbearable that Consciousness itself all
being should cease to exist that would
be better nothing is better than
something if something is Rife with
suffering and you can derive that
conclusion and you'll be driven to it in
some
of the farther reaches of your life when
terrible things happen to you but I
would say
faith is the courage to not take that
path despite the evidence that that
might be justified
and so I think it is a form of courage
in the highest sense and I also think it
is a redeeming form of courage one of
the things I told my daughter who was
very very ill for a very long period of
time and in tremendous pain and
suffering the high probability of
continued slow painful inevitable
degeneration was
do not let your illness do not take
advantage of your illness as an excuse
and I told her that when she was in
grade two you know it's no joke to tell
someone that because I knew she'd had
every reason to be embittered but I also
knew that if she was
in combination with realness the two
things might be worse than fatal and you
know if you don't think there are things
that are worse than fatal you have not
suffered because there are things that
are much worse than fatal and that's
certainly not something you want to do
near a child to rule number eight take
responsibility so one of the things I've
been talking to my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is what would you say
it's a it's a constant refrain in the
book it's one of its underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
you know if you start with the
presumption that there's a baseline of
suffering in life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the Baseline
against which you have to work and and
and it's contemplation of that often
that makes people hopeless and depressed
and anxious and overwhelmed and all of
that and and they have the reasons but
you need something to put up against
that and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the Instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear conscience is different than
happiness that's better yeah that's
better guilting yourself you're not
feeling bad about yourself that's right
you feel that you've Justified you've
Justified your existence right and so
you're not waking up at three in the
morning in a cold sweat thinking about
all the terrible things that you've
involved yourself in what you said to
someone that you shouldn't have said or
how you acted or what opportunity you
lost or or or or yeah or or the things
that you've that you've let go that you
should have capitalized on and all of
that and so if you think about the times
when you're at peace with yourself with
regards to how you're conducting
yourself in the world it's almost always
conditions under which you've adopted
responsibility right at least the most
the most guilt I think that you can
experience perhaps is the sure knowledge
that you're not even taking care of
yourself so that you're leaving that
responsibility to other people because
that's pretty pathetic and I unless
you're Psychopathic and you know and
you're living a parasitical life and
that that characterizes a very small
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
only are you not taking care of yourself
let's say so someone else has to but
you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that rule
number nine validate your perceptions I
came about the ideas that I'm going to
relate to you
by a variety of roots
conducting investigations in a variety
of disciplines
uh scientific disciplines to the degree
I was capable of doing that and
inquiries into
literary reality
because literature has its reality I
mean not only its existence as
literature which is obviously real but
in what it portrays which is very
interesting because we all know that
literary portrayals are fictional and we
all know that fiction isn't true
but we all know that literature is true
and deep literature is particularly true
and so that's seems to pose somewhat of
a problem
um I came to the ideas that I'm
discussing too because I noted the
emergence of a problem across multiple
disciplines and it's a very serious
problem in fact I would say it's a
problem so serious that it took
three and a half billion years of
evolution to solve
um
and that would be the problem of
perception
you know the world is given to us in our
perceptions and we confuse the world
that we perceive with the actual world
and
we have to because
we're stuck with
our limited and ignorant perceptions and
so
it's necessarily the case that we bump
up hard against the underlying reality
that those perceptions are trying to
represent
I read a paper in the MIT Handbook of
cognitive science a while back it wasn't
the first place I'd encountered this
idea but it was stated pretty briefly
and so it's a good way of laying out the
problem the problem is really one of
interpretation and it bedeviled
or artificial intelligence researchers
who were attempting to produce
functional robots that could operate in
real world environments and you'll note
we have none of those yet although we
are getting much closer
um it bedeviled cognitive scientists and
and psychophysiologists who are trying
to understand visual perception which
turns out to be complicated Beyond
Comprehension I mean we devote about
half our brain
it's really more than that to just
seeing
and it's interesting to
contemplate why that might be if the
world in some sense is given and
composed of
self-evidently apprehensible objects
which it's not
at all
and the problem also emerged in literary
criticism and interestingly enough it's
emergence there
sparked I would say
the culture war that we're all engaged
in at the moment and so this is not a
trivial problem and
the MIT researchers that I described met
in an Aguilar said
it is possible to categorize a finite
number of objects in an infinite number
of ways
and you think well that doesn't sound
like too serious a problem but it's
actually a really serious problem
because it means that any
snapshot of reality let's say any visual
snapshot of reality certainly any
conceptual snapshot of reality like a
book
is subject to an unending number of
potential interpretations and we could
perhaps quibble about whether that's
actually infinite but I don't think
that's really matters there's all sorts
of mathematical discussions about the
true nature of infinity and
that's the point the point is there are
lots of them way more than you could
ever sort through
and so how how do you do it
and how do you do it in such a mat in a
manner that really makes it simple in
some sense because there's the step and
there it is and I walk down and no
problem except like I said took three
and a half billion years to evolve the
platform that made that perception
possible and so if it took God himself
you know three and a half billion years
to manage it then it's a rather
difficult problem to solve
so I started studying cybernetics
neuropsychology
animal behaviorism
literary Theory psychoanalytic theory
existential philosophy biblical studies
physics to a limited degree evolutionary
biology evolutionary psychology
measurement Theory construct validation
Theory all these different diverse
domains of inquiry
trying to triangulate this problem
although more than triangulate because I
was using more than one reference point
it was a good methodological it's a good
method by which to proceed if you can
find an answer that manifests itself in
multiple historically detached
disciplines simultaneously it's some
evidence that that idea is valid you're
you do that with your senses you have
five senses if all five senses which are
quite qualitatively distinct
point to the same thing then you can be
reasonably but not certainly sure that
it's there
up by reasonably but not certainly I
mean
if that was all there was to specifying
the objects of perception properly we
wouldn't have to talk to each other and
find out what other people think
but we do because even with that
quintangulation let's say
we still Orient ourselves unreliably in
the world and Rule Number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is prioritize attention what I think is
at the core of the postmodern critique
um
I don't think you can look at the world
except through a structure of value and
the the English and so you think well
how did the why is literary criticism so
relevant well or become so relevant and
so powerful and I think well
I believe that we see the world through
a narrative framework
and so that if that's true and we could
talk a little bit about that what I mean
by that I think you need a mechanism to
prioritize your attention
and to because attention is a finite
resource and it's costly so you have to
prioritize it and there's no difference
between prioritizing your attention and
imposing a value structure those are the
same thing and then I think that the
mechanisms that we use to prioritize our
attention are stories and that means
that the people who criticize our
stories actually have way more power
than you think because they're actually
criticizing the mechanism through which
we look at the world and so the
postmodernists would say look you even
look at the scientific world through a
value-laden lens and I think yeah you do
uh they're right but what they're not
right about is that the lens is one of
power and now for someone like Nietzsche
the thing about a word like power is you
can expand the thing the borders of the
word to Encompass virtually any
phenomena you want and so that's why I
tried to Define power as my willingness
to use compulsion on you or other people
because power can be Authority power can
be competence I don't mean any of that I
mean you don't get what you to do what
you want I get to tell you course
exactly and uh and I do think the
Marxist types view the willingness to
use coercion as the driving force of
human history and that's really saying
something because that means it's the
fundamental motivation and uh that's a
very caustic criticism and it's easy to
put people back on their heels about
that you know one of the things you see
about capitalists because I've been
stunned to see the CEOs of major
corporations like roll over in front of
these Dei activists I think well what
the hell's wrong with you people you
know you're not even making use of your
privilege and why are you
um well it's not very powerful if you're
the CEO of a major corporation you can't
even withstand some interns who have Dei
ideology it's like it's doing you a lot
of good and uh
so
and why would you produce a fifth column
within your organization that's
completely opposed to the entire manner
in which you do business and the
capitalist Enterprise as such and one
answer would be well we don't think much
about ideas it's like well maybe you
should and and you know you can be
cynical about it and say well it's just
a gloss to keep the capitalist
Enterprise going while appearing to to
meet you know the new demands of of
ethical re of the new ethical reality
which I think is a bad argument too but
more importantly it's that people are
guilty
and the the radicals who accuse us all
historically and as individuals of being
motivated by nothing but the desire for
power
strike a chord especially in people who
are conscientious you know because if
you're a conscientious person and
someone comes to you and says like a
little mob of 30 people says you know
you could be a little more careful in
what you say and do on the racist front
and the sexist front Etc
you're likely to think well
I'm not perfect I probably could be a
little more careful and it's no doubt
that people have been oppressed in the
past and it's also no doubt that in some
sense I'm the undeserving beneficiary of
historical atrocity and so you know
maybe I should look to myself and
that's weaponization of guilt and it's
very effective and it's not surprising
but it's not helpful so you know so so
there's a resentment that drives this
like a corrosive resentment that's able
to weaponize guilt and it's very
difficult for people to withstand it
part of the cultural battle that we all
find ourselves enveloped in is partially
due to the claim that there's virtually
nothing other than the lust for power
and you know I would say
fair enough in some limited sense which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because you see that as a Temptation
that might be powerful enough to bend
and distort you as you attempt to make
your way through let's say the halls of
power
well
[Music]
I heard recently from a reliable source
that Putin's conversion to Orthodox
Christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
I would say that
I would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
we're thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
I would say
again from a clinical perspective
service to others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns I and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and I'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish I'm not saying
that at all I'm saying that one of the
way out one of the roots out of
depression appears to be an increase in
service to other people and I think the
reason for that is because we aren't
power mad demons at the core even though
we may be tempted by such things and
that we find the genuine meaning that
offsets genuine suffering in the genuine
service to others and I think it's a big
mistake to be cynical especially
prematurely about such things as
political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say they're
adversarial and uh and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve
and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere Victory mere
operationalized Victory or instrumental
Victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political Realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often I
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber and that's a
big mistake and you could think about
that more deeply too is that we all have
to put we all need a place to place the
existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history right because even
the grounds we walk on here which this
is a remarkable and wonderful place I
mean English soil is soaked with blood
just like the soil of every place in the
world that's part of the human Heritage
and all of us bear the marks of that
conflict in some sense in our souls
partly because of the possibility for us
to engage in that but also partly
because part of the reason we're here in
all this privilege is because of all
that catastrophe well the best way to
localize that malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing that true source of
malevolence let's say with your mere
political enemies and that isn't to say
that you won't encounter malevolent
Behavior although most of it in the
political sphere as it is everywhere
most of it is more ignorance than
malevolence although willful blindness
certainly plays a large role and so you
need to know what it is that you're
serving and I would say one of the ways
to do that practically are a couple of
ways to do that practically is you need
a good team around you the people you
really trust and who can watch you and
who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing I
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and Power
and so if you know those things if you
know you need to listen you need to get
in touch with the people you're
representing as regularly as you
possibly can and mostly to listen
um I knew a man in Canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success though that he became
the leader of the opposition in Canada
within about 10 years and I asked him
how he did that because it's like well
really how did you do that that's
actually really hard and he said he
would go out from constituency to
constituency and make his stump speeches
but what he really liked was the Q and
A's because people would tell him what
their problems were then he knew what
the problems were and out of the
dialogue would also emerge the answers
that the audience found compelling and
so not only would they tell them what
the problems were but they would tell
him the answers they would like to have
it have have what instituted to solve
those problems it's the same thing that
comedians do when they when they finast
finesse their acts in front of live
audiences before they practice them in
front of a large audience they lit they
tell jokes and the audience see their
laughs or they don't if they laugh then
you keep that joke and if they don't you
throw it out and soon you're just as
funny as the audience can possibly
manage and it's the same thing you can
also do that in a dark manner by the way
which is what Hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for response and collect those and
so then you become the embodiment of The
Shadow of Your people so I would
recommend that you probably don't do
that I don't know how many of you have
read dostoevsky's crime and punishment
but I would highly recommend that in
crime and punishment the protagonist
commits the perfect murder and he has
his reasons for it and many reasons
because Dostoevsky didn't mess around
when he wanted to give someone reasons
he gave them reasons and raskolnikov
that main character had reasons for
murder and then he commits his murder
and he gets away with it
but things don't go well for a skolnikov
because one of the things he finds out
is that the riskalnikov that you were
before you committed the murder
is not the same as the riskolnikov as
you are after you've committed the
murder and there's a dividing line there
that you don't
it's like the red pill I guess right
it's in like it that's the Matrix
correct the red pill
and once there's certain actions once
you take them there's no going back
and so that's what crime and punishment
is about and riskolnikov tortures
himself to death well not literally but
metaphysically psychologically because
he cannot tolerate
breaking the great moral code
and so it's a great book it's truly a
great book and and it's also
extraordinarily like it's a it's a it's
a it's a murder mystery thriller as as
well as being a deep philosophical book
so if you're in the mood for you know a
murder mystery thriller that's also a
deep philosophical book then that's the
one for you you speak about the concept
of the Soul
um do you associate this with any
psychological constructs
not any psychological constructs that
are more valid than the notion of the
Soul
you know there's there's I would say
what we mean by soul is something like
animating spirit
and you might say well what's a spirit
and well that's actually rather easy to
answer so when a child of four is
playing house
let's say what a child of four is
playing house she
acts out the role of the mother
but acting out that's a strange thing
right because she doesn't literally
duplicate in her actions or her
Perceptions in the game what she
observed her mother literally doing so
for example she didn't go into her
mother's bedroom when her mother awoke
and watched her turn her head in a
particular way to awaken and count the
number of blanks so that she could mimic
that in her play and you know you think
that's absurd but it's not absurd if
it's just mimicry it's not it's
unbelievably sophisticated so what the
girl does is she watches her mother
manifest maternal Behavior across a vast
array of instances and she integrates
that with the image of the mother she's
received from all the books she's been
read and all the little movies she's
watched the Disney movies and so forth
and she abstracts out the animating
principle of the maternal and then she
embodies that in play and usually with a
little boy and that's practice for
what's going to come later it's
unbelievably sophisticated and she's
embodying a spirit and the spirit there
is the abstraction of the central
animating principle from multiple
embodiments of its manifest station and
if you think children can't do that well
then you don't know anything about
children because they do that all the
time in their pretend play which is a
necessary precursor to healthy
psychological development and so part of
what we refer to as the soul is the
presence of that Spirit or maybe even
the capacity of embodying such spirits
and it's very difficult to know how deep
that goes
you know I had a vision at one point of
all the men in my life who've been
particularly influential in a benevolent
way
you know and so and you think well just
a mirror notion of the idea that there
could be a benevolent way that would
unite the acts of benevolence across a
series of men that's all comprehensible
to you that's you take that as a matter
of course when you say that there are
such things as good men and you can
identify them right something stable
about whatever is good across multiple
manifestations of of incarnation let's
say and I saw that transform into the
the father person of the Trinity as the
embodiment of that benevolent Spirit now
I don't have any idea what that means
metaphysically because who does but but
that
that Spirit manifesting itself within is
certainly part of what we refer to when
we talk about the soul and you can see
that shine through people I mean it's
part of what gives someone Charisma it's
part of what elicits the instinct to
imitate in you
you know when you see that even in
simple things when you see a remarkable
athlete do something incredibly athletic
to put the goal to put the soccer ball
the football ball through the net
to score the goal and everybody leaps to
their feet in celebration of that well
that's that's a celebration of the
Divine capacity to hit the target dead
on and it grips you at such a a low
level way down inside your soul that
you're compelled to your feet to cheer
and you don't even know what you're
doing
but you enjoy it that's for sure and
that enjoyment is also a sign of the
depth and utility of that response you
see this in all all the things that
people do that are you know so-called
popular entertainment it's unbelievably
sophisticated
the soul is participating in that in the
fullest extent and you know you can say
well there's no use for the religious
there's no necessary use for the
religious terminologies like well until
you come up with a better word there's
plenty of use for it because it's a very
complex and deep phenomena and to you
know just
casted into the realm of superstition in
some casual manner is it's just not
helpful not in any possible it's not
helpful scientifically it's not helpful
ethically it's not helpful existentially
try treating someone for a while as if
they don't have a soul
just really I mean it just you know
treat them like a deterministic machine
if that's your belief
really act it out you'll be like the
most hated person in town in about 15
minutes well I mean what do you make of
practical evidence like that I mean you
interact with people as if they're free
Souls capable of choosing between good
and evil that's what you do all the time
and maybe you can Addle yourself out of
that by some ridiculous rationalist
ideology but that just means you're kind
of a gabbling fool and it's just going
to make you trip over things you don't
even notice in all of your social
interactions and you tell me I don't
care how you think philosophically or
ideologically you bloody well know that
what I just said is true
so and that's true even when you're
interacting with an infant or a small
child it's true when you're dealing with
someone who's elderly and virtually
incapacitated in every way you still see
that Divine spark for lack of a better
term and we do lack a better term by the
way you see that everywhere if your eyes
are open and if you're willing to see it
and to the degree that you're responsive
to that then
your actions are Guided by love and your
words are Guided by truth you need that
instinct for meaning too so and we
should get this real straight why do you
need it
well you need it because life is really
really difficult right I mean people
have a rough time of it there's plenty
of suffering in life and everyone is
going to encounter it right there you
don't you know you learn this as a
clinical psychologist and you know this
generally you know unless you're an
extraordinarily fortunate person
um you don't have to talk to someone for
very long
and and really talk to them and get
beneath the surface until you find you
know there's a tragedy or two or three
or ten lurking not very far beneath the
surface someone in the family is very
ill there's a childhood history of
extreme pathology alcoholism somewhere
in the family maybe a touch of insanity
someone has cancer you know someone some
an older relative is dying there's
financial trouble there's economic
trouble there's marital trouble it's
like life is trouble and now you know
that doesn't mean it's all trouble but
man it's trouble and sometimes it's it's
a lot of trouble and sometimes it's so
much trouble that you can you can barely
stand it and and you see that because
people you know people get depressed and
they commit suicide and the reason they
do that is because they think not being
is better than being and that's quite
the decision you know so and and it's
not that uncommon among people who are
depressed and so it's it's a it's a very
it's a very important thing to consider
and it isn't just a matter of depression
and suicide that's bad enough but you
know if you're unhappy because your
suffering has pushed you past the point
of your ability to cope then there's all
sorts of other things that can happen to
you that aren't directed towards you you
can become cynical and you can become
bitter and you can become cruel and you
can become narcissistic and deceitful
and arrogant and and it's like
everything's for you and then you're out
for Revenge that's a nice one I don't
know against who but maybe everyone
maybe even including you because you're
not happy about the rule you've played
in generating your own misery I mean
there's a lot of Darkness underneath the
suffering and so and and that's that's
an ever-present existential danger for
human beings you know we're aware of the
future we're aware of our fragility
we're aware of our mortality it's
something that makes us truly unique
truly conscious in a way that no other
creature is and capable of things that
no other creature can do but also
bearing an unbelievably heavy
existential load were the only creatures
that have to always contend with the
fact that we're finite and that everyone
we know is in the same position that
allied with the suffering and so that's
there all the time and and you know even
even in in the brightest moments in some
sense you know in in Renaissance
paintings in still life they used to put
a Memento momentum Mori often in the in
the still life like a skull somewhere in
the corner or sometimes sometimes in in
a very strange perspective so that you
could only see the skull if you were
standing like right beside the painting
instead of dead on but the idea was to
always remember you know that everything
that exists is Tainted or touched with
the with the with the with it with the
taint of mortality and you know that's
rough but there's some useful things in
it it keeps you awake and it keeps you
focused if you're careful but it also
does indicate to you if you think about
it the necessity of having a meaning in
your life because because
if it's true intrinsically that life has
this unbearable element of suffering
which seems to be completely in in what
would you say indisputable as far as I'm
concerned and it's worse than that too
because it's not just suffering it's
suffering contaminated with malevolence
right it's bad enough to have something
bad happen to you and it's likely that
that'll happen but it's even worse for
you to do it to yourself and to know
that you did it that's rough and it's
also extraordinarily rough to be
betrayed by someone else or you know
tyrannized by your own culture and so
and that's that's not just suffering
that's like unnecessary and pointless
suffering that's been directed at you by
something that wants that to happen and
so both of those are very very powerful
let's say archetypal forces suffering
and malevolence and we have to deal with
them at every level of reality and you
need something to you need something to
push back against that it's not optional
if that's the default position and I
think it's the default position like a
meaningless life isn't meaningless
it's suffering and malevolence
that's not good and and if that's acted
out you know that that's the other thing
if that's acted out and I've read the
accounts and the actions of people
who've
taken a very vicious turn into the
darkest parts of the underworld
consequence of their resentment and
their malevolence and then their desire
to make everything in the world suffer
for the outrage of its existence man I
mean that's how we turn things into hell
if you want to know why totalitarian
States take the brutal twists they take
and why people are motivated to do the
absolutely terrible things that they do
well that's why is that the suffering
and the malevolence that's intrinsic to
life overwhelms them and and they turn
and they turn in a very bad Direction
and then they make everything that's
already bad way worse and we're very
very inventive at such things and so
that's not good unless that's the path
you want that's a bad idea you need an
alternative and that's meaning so then
you can imagine
I have this Cottage
in Northern Ontario and
we're fortunate
uh it's dark there and so you can go
down to the dock at night and in the
clear sky you can see the vast array of
the infinite heavens arrayed above you
you know and it's something that people
who live in cities really don't get to
experience anymore they don't experience
the sunset which we also go out on our
boat and watch pretty much every day
and that puts you in in touch with what
inspires awe
now when that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's it's a deep
biological experience it's in it's
embedded in the prey response to a
predator in part you know because if you
if you feel awe sometimes you can feel
that with music a lot of people are high
in openness to experience will feel that
quite frequently under the effect of
aesthetic experiences interestingly
enough their hair stands on in that's
pilo erection that's what a cat does
when it's frightened by a dog like the
little boy at the beginning of the story
you know the cat puffs up to look big to
be like medic hat so that it can contend
with it can contend with dogs or at
least it can look like it might and so
when when it sees a dog the sight of the
dog calls the best fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
you know
it calls to you
right Dr Dawkins sent me a paper last
week
in preparation for a discussion that
we're going to have tomorrow and it was
very interesting paper and I think I
read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning animal has to be a
microcosm a model of the environment
within within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant and even
your encounter with mortality your
encounter with finitude and limitation
all of that in relationship to the
infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the Divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity it's
time we woke up and realized it you have
to make a decision in your life and this
is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying here's where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being as good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you love
other people you want the best for them
you want the best and you deserve the
best in them if you love them and you
trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
I don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take I think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage and
and so that's how that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult it seems to me that
that's laudable that seems to me that we
spontaneously admire and would like to
imitate people who are capable of that
and so you see that when you have a job
or you and you encounter a boss who
takes you under his or her wing and
helps develop you or you find a teacher
who's particularly inspiring or you work
for an entrepreneur who's inspiring and
who also opens doors for you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities your perceptual structures
are determined by the goals that you
have at hand I mean some of that's
that's not completely true because your
perceptual systems also have limitations
right there's things you can't see or
hear even if you need to so there are
limitations built in but within that set
of limitations you're still trying to
tune your perceptions to your motivated
goals and that's also very useful to
think about when you're trying to
understand artificial official
intelligence because for human beings
without goals there's no perception
because there's no filtering mechanism
that you can use to determine the level
of resolution at which you perceive
anyway so there's the there's a thing
made of smaller things which are made
out of smaller things and it's so it's
kind of my iconic representation of the
complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and I think if you
just look at it you can detect it's like
a Necker Cube you know those cubes that
that are line drawings that you can see
the front of and then it'll flip to the
back have you seen those so this is kind
of neck or cube like or at least it is
for me in that when I look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes I focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes I can see these other lines
and then sometimes I'll focus on that
square and sometimes I can see the
little dots there maybe one dot and my
perceptions are going like this trying
to fit a pattern to it and I you can
kind of detect that when you're watching
it and so I would say well you have the
options of perceiving this in its full
complexity or you can simplify it
essentially there's lots of ways you can
simplify it but some of them are laid
out there so you take the complete
complex thing you make a low resolution
representation of it so that's it's
rough that's the rough area that all
those dots occupy that's the rough area
broken down to its four most fundamental
quadrants that might be how you would
look at it if if this was a map of an
orchard and you were trying to walk from
south to North that would be a useful
representation this combines this and
this that's
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then I think what happens
is we have the thing in itself and then
we simplify it with a perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when I throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do I
and I'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel because the novel
comes alive in your imagination in your
own idiosyncratic way and it wouldn't if
you didn't understand the references of
the novel right the novelist has to
assume that your basic perceptual
structures and your intuitions and your
instincts are basically the same as his
or hers because otherwise they have to
assume that because otherwise they would
be lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic often for
example if you start reading Victorian
novels you may find that it takes a
while to get into them because the
presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations there's so many rules
that are great but what do you think is
probably if if somebody was to read
those books and there's one rule that
you like this rule out the 24 I've given
you over these past few years you can
absolutely not get this one wrong which
rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop saying things that you
know are lies and that will change your
life
if you do that and it's crazy
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
and you think well I'm just lying to
other people no you're not you can't
just lie to other people because what
you say becomes you especially if you
practice it because we build ourselves
out of words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like don't don't say things you know to
be false that's a that's a good start
man and it aligns yourself with the
truth and that like how can that be a
bad idea imagine that what is true
reflects reality which is sort of the
definition of true how can
failing to align yourself with reality
work how is that possibly going to work
well you say well I can you know if I
lie I get away with something it's like
no you don't
you know I I tell you I swear this is
true
in all of my clinical practice
I have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see what your lies cost or too blind
or too self-deceptive you just don't see
it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
God fundamentally that's a very old idea
and it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
I got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's going to snap back and hit you in
the face and that's that's life man you
warp the structure of reality you think
you are someone who can warp the
structure of reality with your words and
get away with it really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not God treat yourself
like you're someone that you care about
see I read this I read this this
piece of work by Jung a long while back
and it was a meditation on
um the injunction to treat your neighbor
as as you would like to be treated
something like that and what Jung
pointed out which I really liked was
that that wasn't an injunction to be
nice to other people it was an
invitation to reciprocity it was
something like this it's like
you should figure out how you would like
to be treated like you were taking care
of yourself not how you would like
people to respond to you it's more
important than that it's like imagine
you had a child that you really cared
for and and someone said well people
will treat this child exactly like you
want them to but you have to figure out
what that is and so then you'd have to
sit down for like a month and you'd
think okay well how do you want your
child to be treated you don't want
everyone just to be nice to them you
know you want people to challenge them
and you want people to discipline them
and you want people to tell them when
he's wrong it's like you don't just want
everyone to be nice that's that's
pathetic it's pathetic there's no
challenge in that and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have to figure out how would you
like to be treated
and while you'd like people to farm all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no that's not something
you'd wish for for someone that you were
taking care of and then then there's an
additional problem which is it's often
the case that people will treat other
people better than they treat themselves
that happens extremely frequently so one
of the things I pointed out chapter two
was that
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you your
prescription medicine you'll go buy the
medicine and you will give it to the dog
and you will do it properly but if you
go yourself to a doctor and you get a
prescription there's one there's a 30
chance you won't even pick up the
medication and if you do there's a 50
chance that you won't administer it to
yourself properly
and so I really thought about that when
I first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts I thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously
but for something you care about and
your conscientious enough so you'll
actually do it so like why wouldn't you
do it for you your dog likes you you
know even your dog would rather that you
did but but you don't you don't and and
it's actually one of the reasons that
modern medicine doesn't work nearly as
well as it could because people just
don't take their medication you make the
world a much better place a much worse
place if you don't take care of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapter is about
it's partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that Western
Civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark and so it's necess not
just so that you feel better not just so
that you're a number one Lobster none of
those things you need to take care of
yourself because you're in the best
position to do that and it's necessary
for you to take care of yourself despite
the fact that we're mortal and
vulnerable and self-conscious and
capable not only capable of doing
terrible things but actually do them
despite all that you you're still you
still have that responsibility most of
your sanity
is socially distributed
and what I mean by that is well let's
say that you know how to behave you're
well socialized you can play with others
now I said already in this conversation
if you didn't learn to play with others
between the time you were two and four
you will never learn
and psychologists have beat their heads
against the wall trying to rehabilitate
anti-social children they can't do it
after the age of four
is it because areas of the brain just
don't develop
well it seems to be partly because the
kids fall farther and farther behind so
let's say you make the leap from
egocentric dependence on your mother at
two and three to immersion in a peer
group well then then you you pick peers
that are at your same development level
and you chase each other up the
developmental ladder and the longer
you're out of that the farther you fall
behind
and so you know kids five-year-old kids
might come across another five-year-old
kid who tends to cry too much if they
don't get their way and they'll say we
don't want to play with the baby and
what they're saying is we have to find
someone who's at our developmental level
shares our developmental Horizons so
that we can mutually scaffold our
further development now they're not
going to say that obviously but that's
the situation and kids test each other
out when they first meet so do adults
game game game game game can you play
are you playing at the same level as me
I'm playing my game at the level that
will further my development
can you play along with me if not well
maybe you're lower in status and I can
pull you up as a mentor maybe you're
hiring status and I can learn from you
but if you're a peer we can play
together anyways if you're acceptable to
your peers
and you behave well they'll accept you
and then they tell you all the time if
you're acting appropriately you know if
your jokes are funny if you're
dominating the conversation if you're
bringing something of value to the table
and all you have to do is pay attention
to the social cues and you'll keep
yourself regulated all of the people
that I know who have become successful
in any way use a structured means to
organize their time they have lists of
things to do like they have every day
there's a list of things to do that day
every week There's a list of things to
do that week every month there's a list
of things to do that month you know at
every level of temporal resolution
there's a sequence of plants and those
plans are implemented on a day-to-day
basis you you cannot be
and successful isn't the right way of
thinking about it because I'm not
thinking about you know I'm not really
thinking about rising up the corporate
ladder you know you know what I mean and
that's sort of what success has come to
mean in our culture that isn't what I
mean
you can have a life that you're going to
find acceptable without that because you
need the vision and the plans to give
you purpose and Direction that's where
all your positive emotion comes from all
your motivation is laying out plans that
are worth attaining and then observing
yourself moving towards them that's the
source of most positive meaning and then
also without that structure
you're so lost that you're going to be
anxious and overwhelmed it's really like
being in a foreign country like isolated
and alone with no map I don't know where
the hell I am I don't know what the hell
I'm doing you know the rains are going
to come the storms are going to come and
maybe it's winter and I don't know where
I am or where I'm going you have to be
very careful with your hierarchies
because they tend towards inequality of
distribution that's one problem once
they're established they always also
tend to a form of tyranny because once a
hierarchy of competence has been
established it can be invaded by people
who use power as the means to attain
status in the hierarchy and that can
corrupt and and Destroy even the entire
hierarchy so you have to be on guard for
that plus if your hierarchy becomes too
steep in its distribution so it's too
tiny a fraction of people at the top and
two great an agglomeration of people at
the bottom especially under conditions
of genuine privation then the people at
the bottom are it's not only unjust and
unfair and producing excess suffering
but the people at the bottom have
nothing to lose and might as well just
flip the hierarchy on its end and that's
not a good way to produce a sustainable
Society you don't want to put people in
a position where they have nothing to
lose especially if you have something to
lose but also just with regards to
principles of like fairness and Justice
let's say don't recommend any changes
that you wouldn't suffer for if they
failed
how's that
and that's the problem with large-scale
political action it's like well here's
how we should change things it's like
well they changed them it's well it
fails it doesn't bother me it doesn't
hurt me I'm not involved in it it's like
you should be careful when you try to
change things to make sure you suffer
for your own stupidity of course head
down endurance and that'll get you
through bad times that endurance it's
it's it's such an under
represented virtue that ability to
trudge forward under a
trudge forward unhappily under uh
unfairly burdensome load is a testament
to character if you can and then it's
something that should be
encouraged and
valued
so you know and I'm not making the claim
that people who are depressed who can't
get out of bed lack endurance some do
and some don't because depression comes
in very varied uh degrees of intensity
and and you can be laid out completely
by depression
so I'm not trying to make some arbitrary
judgment about who's got endurance and
who hasn't you can't do that from the
outside but I can say that endurance is
one of the tools you have to deal with
chronic discomfort and pain
you know and even if you have chronic
pain it's interesting because it's very
much allied with depression by the way
all of the research on chronic pain back
pain for example indicates in chronic
pain of All Sorts is that
the more you allow your pain to render
you inactive the worst outcome including
exacerbation of the pain and depression
is a pain disorder and so that's very
much worth thinking about too it's like
move forward move forward move forward
you know and if you need to talk to
somebody about what your plan is for the
day or the hour or the week then do that
as well and perhaps you also have to
help get the people around you to help a
bit I need a little bit of help getting
up in the morning I need to have
breakfast made for me so that all I do
when I get up in my in my terrible state
of fog and confusion and terrible
anxiety and depression is I have a
shower because that's what happens first
and then the next thing is I eat and
then that's better you're at least
you're out of bed and moving and that's
that's a start you know so
and then you endure in Hope and that's
how it is and you do the same thing when
someone in your family is sick or when
you're facing a death all of that it's
like one bloody foot in front of the
other up the hill I've had clients many
clients in their 30s who are trying to
this is more true with women I would say
a lot of women who are very high
achieving who establish their career
goals at 30 and then
want to differentiate differentiate out
their life they want to have a husband
they want to have a family they're
trying to figure out how to do that and
one of the things I've noticed that
around 30
you really have to stop comparing
yourself in some ways to other people
and the reason for that is that the
peculiarities of your life are so
idiosyncratic that there isn't anyone
really all that much like you you know
because the details of your life happen
to matter and so maybe you compare
yourself to some rock star or something
like that and you know the person's rich
and famous and glamorous and all that
but you know they're alcoholic and they
use too much cocaine and they've had
three divorces and it's like how the
hell do you
make sense out of that is that someone
that you should judge yourself harshly
against or not the answer is you don't
know because you don't know all the
details of their lives and who do you
know that you can compare yourself to
that's easy you yesterday
so here's a good goal it's something
like well aim high and I really mean
that it's like and we'll talk about that
a little bit too aim high but use as
your control yourself it's like so your
goal is to make today some tiny
increment better than yesterday and you
can use better you can Define better
yourself this doesn't have to be some
imposition of external morality you know
you know where you're weak and
insufficient where you could improve you
think okay well this is what I'm like
yesterday if I did this little thing
things would be just an increment better
and well that's a great thing because
you get the ball rolling and incremental
Improvement is Unstoppable you can
actually implement it and it starts to
generate Pareto distribution like
consequences it starts to compound and
I've seen that happen in people's lives
over and on people write me all the time
and tell me that they're doing that but
I've seen that happen in people's lives
continually they make a goal a goal that
the goal should be
how could I conceive of my life so that
if I had that life it would clearly be
worth living so I wouldn't have to be
bitter resentful deceitful arrogant and
vengeful you act out the things that you
would do when you're normal even when
you're depressed you know you don't want
to see people well it doesn't matter you
go see them because it's better than not
seeing them you know and you find when
you do see them that it's better it'll
go better than you think but you can't
isolate yourself and you're anxious and
so you want to avoid you don't want to
go out you'd rather stay home and sit in
the chair and just sit there and like in
a frozen positions like you can't do
that you have to go out and go grocery
shopping and go out and have coffee and
all of those things it doesn't matter
whether you enjoy them it matters that
you do them because that's what you do
that's what you do in order to maintain
your health
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
some powerful habits to start every day
with check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there but if
there's something inside of you that is
restless for that next level we're gonna
have to start measuring if you don't
measure it you can't improve it you know
if you ever try to lose weight or gain
you've noticed apparently this is
weightlifting I'm talking